this episode is sponsored by keeps we
all know the secret to being an OP anime
protagonist is having amazing hair made
me one powerful main character without
hair I'll wait
shut up that's why this episode is
sponsored by keeps keeps is a
subscription service that focuses on
making it easier and more affordable for
men to treat their male pattern baldness
online a licensed doctor will review all
your information online choose the right
treatment plan for you and then ship
that plan right to your door two out of
three men will experience some form of
male pattern baldness in their life so
look to your left look to your right
one of those imaginary men sitting next
to you has a full healthy head of hair
better watch yourself baby see the key
to all this is prevention if you're
gonna start doing 100 push-ups 100
sit-ups and 100 squats every day you
better be doing it after you start
taking keeps so what are you waiting for
keep your hair today by clicking the
link in the description or going to
keeps.com for 50 off your first order
that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash gig up for 50 off
thank you for keep sponsoring us today
let's get on with the video It's The
Fall season which means 2021 is almost
over and this is the last season of
anime for the year now this year we've
had some of the best seasons of anime in
history and summer and we've made it
just in time for Halloween too so let's
see if there's anything suitable for
that for once hmm we've got my sugar
tensei nope more 86 nope kirby-san yeah
that's a definite note oh wait
miyonikuchan all of a sudden a girl is
able to see monsters around her instead
of running away she tries to ignore them
okay this seems pretty creepy let's see
how scary this is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is based on a highly acclaimed
manga and I can kind of see why the
first episode sets up a story that you
can tell is going to cut deep and hit
hard whether you're into fine art or not
I think my favorite scene in this first
episode is when we see the main
character realize his love for art he
fumbles around with the colors trying to
paint his exact vision of shibia in the
morning he's desperate to get his image
out on paper but he gets frustrated that
he lacks the skills to do so you can see
a fiery passion awakened inside of him
he's never cared about anything else
before but this is what he wants to do
he's truly discovered something new that
he loves in life
and then the guy next to him just goes
egg style bye
this I'm this guy I actually read the
first volume of the manga ages ago and I
stopped because I was like yeah this is
gonna get an anime adaptation I'm gonna
wait for that and all I can say is that
if this is a faithful adaptation this is
going to be one of the shows to look out
for because from what I've heard and
from what I've read of the manga it is
pure art
eh uh
foreign
sorry to bother you I'm just working on
the storyboards right now and uh it's
just something very basic to do with the
main girl we've got this scene coming up
and I just wanted to know how you wanted
it to be framed
pointed out her ass
now as much as I'm enjoying this I'm
getting very confused as to how the show
wants me to feel I get the vibe that
this is meant to be a horror comedy I
like the concept and it's certainly
entertaining seeing a poor innocent girl
trying her best to ignore terrifying
ghosts and monsters but then on top of
that the entire thing seems hornier than
a gentian player looking up gun you fan
art which I guess shouldn't be
surprising coming from the studio that
gave us men of culture the animation but
what really throws me off is that the
ghosts are genuinely unnerving like the
scary bits are actually scary it has
better horror than most horror anime but
then it cuts off to some chord in 4k
unreal 5 high definition renderer
obviously girls camel toe Honestly
though I'm gonna keep watching because I
do think it's an original take and I
think it's definitely enjoyable seeing
her try to deal with all these different
aberrations coming at her
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang
do you ever look back at the Cold War
era Space Race and think to yourself
anyone else feel this missing vampires
we got definitely not the Soviet Union
competing with off-round America to do
good for their glorious Nation by
sending the first vampire into space and
I mean this is certainly a unique
concept but I've said this before but
I'm just not a fan of vampires
[Music]
like I was saying I'm a big fan of any
stories with vampires is this a cute
tsundere with a top-tier pout face and a
smug face to boot yo yo yo yo yo stop
stop stop guys guys guys stop trying to
claim her his new waifu okay stop
she's our wife I like this one yes okay
it's because of the Cinderella right you
got me but like how can I not I mean you
know what cinderies be like
okay
[Music]
you know when I hear about some new IP
anime getting made that's meant to
promote some upcoming mobile game I was
like oh wake me up when the real shit's
coming out but then you see a scene like
this
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and then you're just like oh
okay this is some main monitor [ __ ] you
know I've forgotten how hard mad house
would go with some help from mapper of
course but gorgeous animation aside I
just loved the [ __ ] designs and
Aesthetics of this show with a quiet
place-esque World filled with monsters
attracted to music superhumans fight
back with abilities that use the power
of classical music set in the backdrop
of America it's such a mishmash of
bizarre ideas that just works this is
one of those shows that drags you in
with the rule of cool and I'm just a
sucker for anything that uses music it's
one of the core aspects of the show so
I'm definitely excited to see where this
one goes oh hell yeah Mecca fans be
eating good this year I mean just look
at this Sunrise are finally going back
to their Roots see call me old Fashions
but I like my mix like I like my woman
2D what god it feels so long since we've
seen just traditional 2D mechs from a
new original Mech IP coming from Sunrise
even if here they've essentially just
made Code Geass double O all right I'm
just being facetious I mean yes you do
have a Japan that's been conquered
whereas citizens are all treated as
sub-human and it's all up to a single
and probable young boy to save the
nation but remember code gear started
off with them joining a resistance
terrorist organization but this is
nothing like that look they even say so
foreign
okay well I know this looks bad but
we're not fighting or anything
all right well that was just
self-defense we're not going out there
blowing [ __ ] up
I'll just play the [ __ ] Code Geass
theme
you know when you get this feeling about
a show that even if the general
consensus is that it's not the standout
show of the Season it might just be your
standout show of the Season well that's
soccer gun for me soccer gun is a
massively under what show about a
father-daughter ragtag Duo on a Grand
Adventure in the depths of a labyrinth
World filled with Kaiju piloting a Mecca
to help a human civilization that's
trapped underground if this sounds kind
of like made in lagaan with a side of
decadence you'd be absolutely right but
what really drew me in and what makes it
stand out to me is the main Duo
sometimes you just see characters that
instantly click their chemistry was an
instant sell for me and after a single
episode I was already dangerously
invested in their relationship [ __ ] this
season's best girl we found best
daughter it was fun it was Charming it
was emotional Amplified by the bombastic
osc because my God does the music kick
[ __ ] ass
there are a few things that are rough
around the edges the CG looks Jank and
the hype scenes aren't on the same
Master Class level you'd find on
something like a trigger show I can see
why this didn't immediately Stand Out To
The Wider crowds but I feel such a
strong heart behind it out of everything
I've watched this one is the one that
put the biggest smile on my face and I
know that if it's able to hit the marks
I think it can hit this is gonna be one
of my favorites of this season I don't
know guys I've just got a really good
feeling about this one next one we have
continues to have one of the most
impressive productions for an isakai
anime TV series I've seen though if
you're looking for something in the same
vein the far away Paladin is a new show
that seems to have the same thoughtful
approach to the World building and
characters without the horny in a show I
can best describe as if Dark Souls
characters Had A Slice of Life spin-off
restaurant another world gone last
season
that's my notes we've got some guy who
opens up a drugstore in another world in
the most unique concept we've ever seen
in an isikai since last season's
drugstore
in another world there's an Easter guy
starring a main character who is and I
quote an ugly revolting dirty smelly fat
ass made by an animation studio called I
share you not feel children's playground
did edp-455 make a [ __ ] isaker from
the creators of Death Note we got
Platinum end featuring incel lights
Yagami taking part in some Divine death
game where the winner gets to become God
whatever that means this looks like some
edgy fun seems like it's gonna have the
same kind of over-the-top deep thinking
mind games you've seen in Death Note
except this time there's a cute Kawaii
Angel who seems a bit too trigger happy
with the idea of murdering people we
don't know who the rest of the gold
candidates are yet but I mean they've
already given us a glimpse of everyone
we need to look out for so you know what
I'm gonna get ahead of the curve let's
put our detective hats on and see what
we got to worry about hmm all right
we've got a spiky heads guy a teenager
an adult a child a school girl a man I
have three words for you
John Wick and Sakai if you're getting
bored of the usual epic game and nerd
protagonist gets Easter Garden suddenly
becomes a sigma male so let me introduce
you to this we've got the world's
greatest assassin who dies and gets
hired by an isakai goddess to
reincarnate so he can assassinate the
hero of the fantasy world this is
honestly got a really interesting take
on the genre and it's just so refreshing
to see a main character who was actually
a badass before he got isakai for once
it's ready to see nisakai where the
guy's life before is just as interesting
as his life after he got reincarnated
and you know for such a refreshing take
on the usual isakai protagonist I wonder
what kind of Genius came up with this
oh
I've made a severe and continuous lapse
in my judgment oh yeah baby say goodbye
to Saucy Baka and say hello
to cheeky senpai
oh kill this dick what's glitter in half
and then there's ranking of Kings now
I'm gonna be absolutely honest I
completely looked over this one because
well it looks like a kid's show okay but
Google you shouldn't judge a book by its
cover you know I know I know but shut up
okay I'm not the biggest fan of the art
style the world is very ghibli-esque
which is something that doesn't appeal
much to me so in an anime season where I
barely have time to watch all the good
shows this [ __ ] matters and I say this
because in spite of all this in spite of
all my preconceptions this to me was one
of the most impressive anime this season
in a world where kings are ranked and
their strengths inspire a nation you
have a weak definite prince who aspires
to be the world's greatest King in spite
of all those in his kingdom doubting him
it's a simple tale that is propped up by
great writing and some of the best
storytelling you can find this season I
came in watching it to take off a box
and I went out almost crying because of
the backstory of this black [ __ ] blob
with eyes I know what the [ __ ] this is I
would say that's a lot of this is
because Studio where they're just on
fire right now but I mean like when the
[ __ ] aren't they I'm not sure if these
[ __ ] are capable of missing because
they've somehow given us yet another
banger
word around the offices you've got a fat
[ __ ] as the veritable waifu flavor of
the month komisan was one of the most
anticipated adaptations this season and
if you don't keep up with the manga
scene you may be thinking all right
what's so special about this waifu
that's got everyone up in arms well you
see Comey
is afraid of social interaction
I knew that I put comey-san in the
category I like to call Discord profile
picture manga you know the type of manga
I swear to God it's made to appeal to
the type of people who still laugh at
the number 69. so I nice so I gotta be
completely honest I came into this
thinking I'm better than this as the
self-proclaimed tsundere loving [ __ ]
Lord I was I wasn't gonna be Charmed by
this girl I mean what's she gonna do
quietly exhale on me you think I'm gonna
fall for the waifu version of heavy
breathing cat but God damn it I can't
man she's just too damn adorable we've
had a fair share of socially awkward
hashtag relatable introverts am I right
kind of shows but this is the first time
I've seen someone with crippling social
anxiety not only that but this is the
best animation I've seen for a slice of
Life show outside of Kyoto animation I
mean some of these shots look straight
up film quality this is looking like
it's going to be one of the most
wholesome feel-good shows of the year
because for real knowing a lot of people
with social anxiety I'm really glad
something like this exists there are so
many people out there who want to open
up but don't have the courage or know
how to do so and even in this first
episode seeing just a glimpse of someone
taking that first step of trying to open
up just melted my heart immediately and
made me hope that someday I could help
someone too take that first step
foreign
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you to keeps for sponsoring me
today and also thank you very much to
Alpha Sigma basil dysfunctional
degenerate lf4 iveedo Jeff lovados
manipla Payne Patchett Pony Stark walzo
and everyone else my patreon for helping
to support me this month as you can see
I'm filming from the trash taste office
right now because my new home is an
absolute state which is the best way I
can describe it because um it kind of
looks like a nuclear bomb just got set
off in there right now so yeah I'm still
setting everything up on my new home so
luckily I do have a office to work in so
it looks like by November time we should
be back on our normal schedule I know
people are just like ah old gigockers
returns it's monthly uploads once again
anyway though that's pretty much all the
updates I've had I'm gonna go back to
building a [ __ ] ton of furniture right
now so hope you enjoyed the video I've
been gig up and I'll see you all next
time